In 1956, a Harvard psychologist named Dr.
George A. Miller did a study a review, for
Psychological Review Magazine behind the magic
of numbers.
And it was specifically focused on the number
7.
And here's what he came up with.
He realized that there is a certain magic
behind us, the audience, the customer, remembering
seven digits.
So for example, he talked about the fact that
phone numbers are seven digits in a phone
number.
As a matter of fact, if you think about, right
now, depending on whatever generation you're
a part of, there used to be a time prior to
having cell phones, we had to remember numbers.
So most people had phone books.
There was a little pocket phone book where
you would write all the numbers down and then
eventually if you said it enough times, you
know it.
Till today I remember phone numbers that we
used 25 years ago.
818-547-073_, and that was my home number.
I haven't used this number for 20 some years.
But these numbers stayed, right?
So he said people can remember generally seven
numbers.
So, phone, seven numbers.
Then you think about seven days in a week.
Very simple.
Seven notes to a music scale.
Seven card stud.
Seven deadly sins.
Magnificent seven.
Even Roman numerals - if you go down, you've
seen these before, where that represents one,
V represents five, x represents 10, L represents
50 - there's names to these.
Unum, all these other things and it goes all
the way down to.
Seven.
There's a lot of magic behind the number seven.
So, Pat, what does this have to do with.
. . I thought the title was how easy it is
to buy your product?
Exactly!
Let me explain to you what I mean by how easy
is it to buy your product.
Seven worked back in the day.
If I were to ask how many phone numbers right
now you know right off the top of your head
- stop everything you're doing, grab a piece
of paper, and write down how many phone numbers
you know off the top of your head, with the
number seven.
See how many you can actually remember.
Don't touch your phone.
Don't look at anything.
Make a list.
Can you remember 100?
Can you remember 50?
What is the limit?
You know why you probably can't think about
50 - odds are, some of you guys may, but not
everybody can remember 50.
Because you don't have to.
So whatever our brain doesn't use ,it doesn't
get any better.
So today, I'm here to tell you the new magical
number for your business, as an entrepreneur
to simplify, and make everything easier for
your customer to buy is the number three.
Three is the new magical number.
Three is the new primary colors is three,
which is what?
Red, yellow, and blue.
If you want to talk about for Photoshop, it's
what?
Red, green and blue, I believe, right?
But it's typically red, yellow and blue.
Three parts of a personality we can remember
by Sigmund Freud - ID, which ID is your animal
instinct, then you have ego, which is your
personality, and then the super ego which
is your subconscious.
Then you have three trimesters in a pregnancy.
We can remember the number three.
Again, Pat, what does three.
. .. three trimesters in business?
So, go back to buying your product.
How many steps do I have to take to buy your
product?
Write it out.
Make a list of it.
For instance, imagine why restaurants came
out with fast food.
And McDonald's started crushing everybody.
Why?
Because look at the steps here.
Look at the steps here.
I'm busy.
It's 5:30.
Or it's 6:30 in the morning, I'm going to
work, or it's 5:30, I'm leaving my job.
I'm driving.
I'm hungry.
My wife calls me and says, "I have nothing
ready for dinner tonight," let's just say.
Or I'm single.
There's no food.
I have to go buy the food, because I'm not
a cook, right?
Or in the morning I want to grab something.
I forgot to make breakfast and I'm going to
grab something.
You're driving and you say, man, do I want
to stop over here?
There's no fast food, look what happens in
the mind.
In your mind, your mind says this.
I have to park the car, turn off the car,
open the door, take my seat belt off.
It's already warm.
Car's heated.
It's cold outside.
I have to step outside in the cold and it
may be raining.
It's not warm.
I have to go inside.
Stand in line with four people ahead of me.
Everybody's trying to order coffee.
Place my order, go wait for this person, and
then get back and turn on the car, put everything
in the car, all the same process I need to
go through, then I go to work.
The mind says, "No, I'm not doing that.
I'm going straight to work."
McDonald's said, "Here's all you need to do.
Come by, and wait, there's five cars ahead
of you.
Place your order, make your payment, pick
up your food.
One, two, three.
Simple.
Fast food became a phenomenon.
They've got 35,000 McDonald's now around the
world.
Very simple.
One, two three.
You got Amazon.
Very simple.
What do you want?
Click on it.
If you're a Prime member, boom, boom, boom.
Simple process.
Three-step process.
The companies I tell you that have the easiest
process of selling a product to a client typically
can scale the most.
Because it's very easy to do.
So, again, going back to the question I asked
you.
Take your product.
I'm a customer, I'm going to buy your product.
What do I need to go through?
Make a list.
Is it 10 steps?
11 steps?
17 steps?
5 steps?
6 steps?
And however many steps it is, see if you can
eliminate it and bring it down to three steps.
See what you can take out.
You know, we don't need this.
I don't even know why we even added this over
here.
You know, we don't need this.
Like in the insurance world, right now I'm
in the insurance world myself and I went to
one of the biggest re-insurance companies
because I have a proposal about what I want
to do for the life insurance industry.
And it's gotten a lot of attention.
Everybody's calling me saying, "Hey Pat ,we
want to possibly put a couple hundred million
dollars into this idea you have, and we want
to see if we can make it work.
What is it?
My idea is very simple.
There's many processes that I'm trying to
take out, that are not necessary.
Purely not necessary.
And it's getting investors' attention, that
want to back this up.
Now we can go from seven steps to buying a
product, or five steps to buying a product,
to all of a sudden three steps to buying a
product, right?
Now, for the longest time insurance required
so many steps to buying a product.
We have a product right now that we're selling
that simply requires three steps.
One, two, three.
We sold more of that policy than anybody else
in the world, including U.S., Canada, and
U.K. and the company is flabbergasted.
But it's because we have the easiest process
of selling the product.
It's one, two, three, and customers today,
millennials, GenX's, GenY's gravitate towards
an easier sales process because back in the
day, it was seven.
Today it is three.
And why is it three?
Let me tell you why it is three, and why you
ought to pay attention to this.
Think about how much is being fed in our minds
today.
Think about how many YouTube videos we watch
per day.
Think about how many Facebook newsfeed you
watch a video.
Another video, another video.
These are all images that are requiring energy.
Your brain is burning calories to watch these
images, the color, the emotions, all this
stuff that you're seeing.
It's sucking up all the data for you to restore
information, right?
It's just taking it, taking it, taking it.
We can't do seven.
We can do three.
Very simple.
By the way, don't try to fight it.
It's like gravity.
Don't say, "I'm going to try to change the
law of gravity."
It's not going to happen.
I'm going to try to change the law of familiarity.
I'm going to try to change some of these laws.
It's not going to happen.
So don't fight it.
But adjust.
Adapt.
And try to figure out a way how you can make
it easy for people to buy your product within
your company.
Now, with that being said, Dennis, let's get
this pillow out here.
We are, I think two weeks away from choosing
one of our pillows.
We're still getting pillows sent over our
way.
But if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
please do so.
Click on the button here to subscribe to the
channel.
And by the way, again, I think YouTube's got
a new thing where you can subscribe, and they'll
email you some of the episodes, or two, click
on the alert right next to subscribe, it's
like an alarm button.
And you'll actually get notified immediately.
Any of the videos that come out, you'll become
one of the first to watch Valuetainment videos
you can comment on it.
But if you haven't subscribed, please do so.
Our goal is to take this channel to a million
subs by the end of 2017.
Just a year ago, we were at 5,000 subs.
Today we're at 155,000 subs, and we'd like
to take this to a million subs by the end
of 2017.
And we feel that with your help, we can do
this.
Because we believe we are the number one how-to
channel for Entrepreneurs on YouTube and we
talk about things that you can actually implement
to help grow your business, not just a bunch
of motivation and regurgitating the same old
content over and over again.
We want to bring your new content that helps
you grow your business.
And if you have any questions or thoughts,
please comment on the bottom.
Take care everybody.
Bye, bye.